errant germi ranque ne peut empêcher ses
larmes de couler son fils richard lui
aussi pleure en annonçant son retrait du
tour de france elle y croyait cette
année la maman comme son fils à une
victoire possible dans la grande boucle
alors le dopage la suspicion le scandale
qui tourne autour de festina elle
préfère ne pas en parler
s'il vous plaît richard virenque a été
l'homme le plus entouré tout le monde le
veut voir tout le monde veut l'applaudir
tout le monde veut les sifflets c'est un
véritable phénomène qui se développe
autour de lui surveillez épiée traquée
on appelle cela vivre sous pression
pourquoi toujours le hic est attaqué
inutile de parler de la sphère richard
ne s'exprime que sur le plan sportif
la chaleur est au rendez vous c'est bon
pour vous aimez la chaleur les banques
qui on regarde feront plus de meute de
journalistes sans un mot il rejoint le
service médical
ce contrôle de routine obligatoire se
transforme en événements premier sourire
quand même du coureur varois
réaliser un bon tour de france
faire de belles étapes de montagne la
présence de virenque en tout cas
continue à susciter des polémiques
lorsqu on efface son long dans le
dernier kilomètre cela provoque la
colère de ses supporters
le camion a pris la fuite les supporters
sont restés virenque est au départ du
tout est à 29 ans le français remporte
sa quatrième étape dans le tour de
france
exclu de l'épreuve l'année dernière
richard virenque signe à morzine son
grand retour